[Musik]
der frühere sowjetische staatschef
gorbatschow ist im alter von 91 jahren
gestorben er galt als einer der väter
der deutschen einheit und als
wegbereiter für das ende des kalten
krieges cdu chef friedrich merz fordert
dass die deutsche staatsspitze für das
begräbnis von gorbatschow nach russland
reist die angst vor einem kalten winter
ist in der ampel deutlich spürbar und
der tank rabatt ende damit herzlich
willkommen zu füllen meine gäste heute
abend sind gewaltpräventionsberater
krassen stasi kennen vermutlich aus
seiner rtl 2 sendung stahlhart gegen
mobbing filmnacht stammgast béla anda
denken sich bestimmt er ist deutschlands
erfolgreichster kommunikationsberater
und war auch mal regierungssprecher
heute abend wird er über das vermächtnis
von gorbatschow sprechen den er auch mal
persönlich erlebt hat der ehemalige
fußball nationalspieler uli borowka
möchte mit seinem eigenen schicksal
andere menschen warnen er sagt er hätte
mich fast zerstört alkoholsucht und
gleichzeitig profifußballer wie das
zusammenpasst das wird er uns erklären
fdp-politiker paul fresdorf wird heute
abend über aufstiegs chancen sprechen
sein appell hat vier darf nicht vererbt
werden starken wir aber jetzt erstmal
mit dem thema von kassen stahl herrstein
würden sie uns verraten was sie bewegt
ja ich bin es mal auf den punkt sowie
millionen deutsche das sehen ich habe
die schnauze voll ich habe die schnauze
voll von einer sozialen
ungerechtigkeit und unserem land und von
einer heuchlerischen doppelmoral der
politik denn wenn man etwas von anderen
fordert opferbereitschaft fordert dann
muss man bei sich selbst anfangen und
das bedeutet vor allen dingen dass man
auch im kanzleramt start nicht
abschaltet auch die klimaanlage
runtergedreht wohl vor allen dingen
einen kanzleramts baustopp denn wenn man
etwas fordert muss man es vormachen und
die menschen und das spürt jeden tag in
hunderten von e mails sind verzweifelt
haben angst alles zu verlieren und wir
helfen gerne aber wir müssen dabei
aufpassen dass wir uns nicht selbst
verlieren und unser land dabei zerstören
und da kommt hier gerade passiert ist
gefährlich und es ist ein kochkessel für
etwas was er noch den straßen weiter
geht und ich komme aus einer ecke wo
gewalt normales und ich möchte das nicht
in unserem land aber was hier passiert
auf dem rücken und den kosten der bürger
muss aufhören aber möchten sie diese
symbolpolitik für unser land sie haben
gesagt da muss das licht ausgemacht
werden und dann hier und warum die
politik sei heute aber wollen sie
generell für dieses land das mit dem
finger gezeigt wird wenn ich das licht
aus hat weil wenn sie das von der
politik verlangen ein verlangen sie das
ja auch eigentlich vom bürger also
grundsätzlich ist es okay wenn man sagt
wir können sparen müssen so sehen wo wir
sparen aber es gibt natürlich kämpfen
also grundsätzlich müssen wir schon
gucken wie weit müssen wir sparen
runterdrehen und was erwartet man also
wenn ein
ministerpräsident aus baden württemberg
sagt wir sollen waschlappen benutzen da
frag ich mich wissen sie machen sie noch
ein bisschen eis gefüllten diva
schnappte sich den auf den kopf
vielleicht wird ja ein bisschen ein
bisschen direkter zugehen bei so viel
scheiße kann man ja nur noch lachen aber
ist ja nicht zum lachen sondern ich habe
so viele menschen die angst haben alles
verlieren wir haben 1000 prozent bald
hier mehr gas wir haben 1000 prozent
mehr mehr sturm was ist denn es wird
leute die sagen dann die müssen sich
darauf vorbereiten 1500 euro für
stromrechnung zu sparen menschen haben
noch nicht mal 1500 euro im monat was
für eine gekühlte scheiße reden die da
wie weltfremd sind die seite teurer
wandlitz blase eingesperrt irgendwo im
anderen universum kommt man zurück auf
der erde und vielleicht sollten wir euch
alle mal daran erinnern wer hier wird
das land eigentlich führten wir ihr seid
angestellter von uns verdammt noch mal
gearbeitet für uns und vielleicht wird
es mal zeit durch zu kehren und dass er
mal auf dem fenster öffnet das einmal
ein bisschen durchzug habe dass eure
gehirne wieder funktionieren und da bin
ich sehr sehr deutlich und ich weiß von
so vielen zuschriften dass die menschen
nicht mehr können und dass diese plant
mitte langsam nicht mehr aushält wird
hier passiert herr borowka spüren sie
auch die wut der bürger die hat
natürlich das bekomme ich auch alles mit
bei uns ist es ja so mit unserem kleinen
gemeinnützigen verein
und über suchtprävention und suchthilfe
die menschen melden sich die haben alle
mehr probleme sie wissen nicht sie haben
existenzangst
versagensängste und das ist das problem
was sie jeden tag immer mit bekomme
immer mehr menschen rutschen ab in die
sucht ja und sie wissen nicht mehr wie
sie es normale leben bewältigen sollen
und das ist ein riesenproblem für uns
als kleiner fall gemeinnütziger verein
das aufzufangen wir sind angetreten
damals und wollte nun zum kinder aus
suchtkranken familien kümmern wir
wollten uns um sportler kümmern die
probleme haben inzwischen ruft jeder bei
uns an
während wegen allen anderen problemen
und wie gesagt der politiker der
journalist der maschinenschlosser alles
ist da und wir haben einfach wir sind
nur zwei leute und da können sie sich
vorstellen was ich danach und nach zu
tun habe seit ein paar jahren und das
ist auch für mich der absteiger und wir
fragen bei dem politiker hier in der
runde er frisst auch wenn sie das hier
hören diese wut also ich spreche ja
schon laut hersteller schreibt ja schon
richtig seine gut hier raus wie sehen
sie das dann würden sie zustimmen dass
die politik zu abgehoben ist nicht mehr
genug bei den leuten oder wird dass hier
völlig falsch gesehen von herr stahl und
herr borowka na ja herr stark ist ja
jemand der gerne zuspitzt und dann ist
er auch laut und sehr bestimmt in seinem
auftreten so kennen wir ihn uns so würde
er von vielen auch geschätzt ich würde
noch gar nicht von wut sprechen wollen
in dem zusammenhang sondern ich glaube
es gibt eine große sorge und eine große
angst was kommt da auf uns zu weil es
noch keine abschätzen kann so richtig
und es wird viele menschen sehr hart
treffen ich glaube das muss man als
politiker hat er noch aussprechen das
ist sehr schwierige monate sind die vor
uns liegen es kommt der winter wir
wissen nicht wie sieht es mit
energieversorgung aus wie wird die
gasversorgung lage aussehen im winter
werden wir noch warme wohnungen haben
reicht das was wir an strom haben um
dann auch gegebenenfalls mit strom zu
heizen herum dann weil den radiator
anzuschalten die wohnung warm zu
bekommen unser netz ist da nicht
wirklich für ausgestattet momentan das
muss man auch sagen wenn man jetzt
anfängt atomkraftwerke abzuschalten in
dieser situation dann wird es kalt und
dunkel in deutschland der diesen winter
und da hat politik eine gestalten rolle
und da muss man aufpassen musste weinen
für eine versorgungssicherheit sorgen
wir müssen gucken dass unser stromnetz
funk zu das aushält weg und so kann ein
messer ausgangslage ist die politik zu
abgehoben der vorwurf ist jäger kleinem
raum von der seite dass die politik
nicht mehr bei den bürgern es stimmt
dass ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht
wenn die sorgen wir glauben sie nicht
wie eine kirche oder wissen sie also ich
weiß es nicht ich kann mir nicht für die
politiker sprechen ich kann nur für mich
sprechen und ich sehe die sorgen neue
nachbarn meiner freundin meiner
bekannten ich weiß dass ganz viele
menschen die nicht in lage sein werden
eine nachzahlung der nebenkosten von
2000 euro auf einmal auf den tisch zu
legen das sind leute wurde disbu am ende
des monats auf anschlag ist und die
sollen dann auf einmal 2000 3000 euro
wir wissen noch nicht was bei dem gas
auf uns zukommt dann auf den tisch legen
können das wird eine große soziale
feuerprobe für unsere gesellschaft wie
wir damit umgehen und da ist die politik
in der verantwortung das ordentlich zu
gestalten wir müssen uns um die kümmern
die es überhaupt nicht können von der
leistung her wir müssen aber auch
aufpassen dass die mitte der
gesellschaft nicht abgehängt wird weil
das ist dann wird es richtig gefährlich
in diesem land wenn wir die arbeiten der
mitte der gesellschaft verlieren weil
ich sagen ich werde von der politik im
stich gelassen ich kann meine rechnungen
nicht mehr bezahlen wie soll ich das
machen das sind unsummen die auf mich
zukommen und da muss die politik bei
antwort finden ich habe sie heute noch
nicht dabei da sage ich ihnen auch ganz
ehrlich aber das ist die gleiche heute
bei ihrer partei regiert damit ja aber
wir müssen natürlich unseren so eine
situation auch ich sag mal herantasten
ja das ist eine situation die wir so
noch nicht hatten in der bundesrepublik
deutschland und der nachkriegsgeschichte
ist es eine feuerprobe die wir so auch
noch nicht hatten bela ist die antwort
für dich zufriedenstellen von der wirtin
na ja wir haben hier zwei im grunde pole
aber die bundes gleiche ausdrucken
eigentlich die die sorge der menschen
was passiert wenn wir immer nur zahlen
zahlen zahlen wenn es keine entlastung
gibt und wenn die menschen nicht mehr
wissen wo sie es hernehmen soll und da
ist es richtig dass es da natürlich
besorgnis gibt und ängste und sorgen und
wut auch was passiert und wie ich damit
umgehe und eine ratlosigkeit was ich tue
das ist ja dass ich diese wut jetzt
schon oder diese sorgen jetzt schon
artikulieren wo die menschen ja nur die
sorgen nur die sorgen haben außer an der
zapfsäule trotz dieses entlastung die im
grunde ja keine gefühlte war
und auf der anderen seite diese großen
hemmer die nachzahlung ja erst noch
kommen also dann kann man sie verstehen
was da los sein wird deswegen bin ich da
fest von überzeugt wir brauchen lösungen
und wir brauchen klare lösungen und
alles was wir heute wieder gehört haben
schöne grüße nach meseberg zu der
klausur die da stattgefunden hat reicht
natürlich nicht also man kann nicht
sagen das ist ein rechtlicher rundfunk
sagt wuchtig nicht konkret genug der das
schon sagt dann ist das schon ein
richtiger hammer also nein ganz im ernst
also da sagen ich kurz euch die
mehrwertsteuer ein bisschen und dann
gebe ich euch 300 müsst ihr aber wieder
irgendwas versteuern weil wir können
euch nicht direkt überweisen und der
arbeitgeber zahlt deshalb aus das
versteht doch kein mensch mehr das
reicht auch nicht diese belastung die
sie genannt haben der überhaupt runter
zu setzen deswegen muss man drei sachen
tun im grunde man muss diesen gaspreis
deckeln da legt man sich den spanischen
ministerpräsidenten ein der das gemacht
hat nach nach sukalos uhr
von der ampel regierung aber er hat's
gemacht ja gesagt hier ist los und den
rest zahlen wir das zweite ist man muss
eigentlich diesen strompreis entkoppeln
vom gas die hängen ja zusammen schafft
wenn der gaspreis nach oben geht da
hilft auch der radiator nicht
so viel verbraucht und man muss
natürlich sich klar machen ich meine sie
haben es erwähnt deutschland ist ein
industrieland deutschland ist ein
industrieland war es energie braucht wir
schöpfen mehr aus unserer
industriefertigung als jedes andere land
in europa das heißt wir werden ob es
einem gefällt oder auch nicht auf
absehbare zeit auch ein dritter
energieträger brauchen weil wind und
sonne reichen nicht dafür und das kann
sonst wo her dass kein gas sein sonst
woher aber das muss man auch anschaffen
dann auch und das sind die drei singende
deckel drauf entkopplung und sich damit
abfinden dass wir auf absehbare zeit das
wird keiner keiner umweltaktivistin
gefeiert aber noch einen zusätzlichen
energieträger der frist auf das klingt
eigentlich haben ganz guten plan warum
setzt die ampel das nicht einfach um
bilder kommen bestimmt gerne vorbei
ja ich denke was die ampel gemacht hat
sind ja schon erste gute schritte ich
meine wir haben entlastungspaket in der
ampel entschlossen dieses in den letzten
jahren so nicht gab mit einem
gesamtvolumen von 30 milliarden was
wusste ich heißt kann ich ihnen heute
auch noch nicht übersetzen das ist ja
noch recht neu aber ich gehe davon aus
wenn wir mit so einem doch
eindrucksvollen wort nach draußen gehen
das ist jetzt nicht mehr um kleine cent
beträge gehen wird sondern dass hier
noch mal eine große entlastung auch für
die mitte der gesellschaft kommen wird
und das muss ich auch tun ich muss die
menschen die arbeiten gehen jeden tag
aufstehen geld verdienen auch geld
wieder geben und ihnen die möglichkeit
geben zu wirtschaften und selbst herr
der lage zu sein aber darum dass
entlastung ein gutes ein guter ansatz
ist ihr handeln sandra nicht so
entlasten wie die menschen entlastet
werden müssten was küche
ist etwa 1000 euro das ist ja das was
ich meinen also wir reden ja hier
wirklich von der entlastung ich bis ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein wir reden
hier von 1500 euro mehrere drei das
viermal soviel und ihr kommt man mit 300
euro ein euro ticket oder was und dann
und das ist das was ich meine das ist
total der eine parallelwelt natürlich
weniger im monat zwischen 10 und 40
tausend euro verdienen dann kann ich
natürlich das vielleicht nicht
nachvollziehen der gemeinde hinte und
hier arbeitet habe dann besser gleich
und ängste und nöte und sorgen sind alle
getan ich habe eine privatinsolvenz ich
hab's halt alles schon hinter mir und
ich sehe die nöte kennenlernen server
machen bei der prävention aufklärung
habe jeden tag mit diesen menschen zu
tun dafür ist ob er kenne ich das sind
auch gute politik wird wenig aber die
viele von denen die stolzen die
vergessen dass sie gestern gesagt haben
und könnte sich morgen nicht mehr daran
erinnern die sind vollkommen abgehoben
und wissen sie wo bleiben sie denn ich
habe kein problem einen herrn scholz und
ihrem boss herrn liter gegenüber zu
stehen aber dafür haben sie nicht den
arsch in der hose sich wirklich mal mit
leuten auseinanderzusetzen die auch mal
wirklich konnte jemand wirklich war
seine sind außerdem sehr schwach
schwächer bis zu schulen die arbeit war
nicht meine antwort das gibt selbst gar
nichts die schreiben und nicht leuten
wie mir zurück weil dann gäbe es ja
beweise und ich habe eine million volle
millionen menschen von reichweite wirkte
transportieren dann guck mal ich meine
antwort nein ich kann verstehen dass man
angst davor hat aber wenn man sich um
diesen posten diese im osten haben
wollte man hat sich darum beworben dann
füllt diesen posten auch aus in der
krise beweist sich der charakter und
warte hier sehe im moment ist einfach
nur noch beschämend einfach nur
beschämend und absolut weg von der
rallye sind sauer weil herr scholz und
herr ländern nicht jedem bürger
antworten sich nicht gegeben
das bestimmt ich nicht jedem bürger aber
ich wäre schon sehr zufrieden dass -show
anderer bürger und schwer doch schon
zufrieden wäre stolz einfach mal fragen
von der presse beantwortet wurde nicht
einfach sagen ihr könnt mich beantworten
mache ich aber nicht ich wäre schon
zufrieden wenn herr scholz die ängste
und sorgen der bürger wichtig nehmen
doch nicht details sagen würde man
sollte die eigenen bürger nicht so ernst
nehmen ich werde das schon sehr
zufrieden wir herr schulz sich daran
erinnern könnte weiter noch von halben
jahr oder von gemacht hat wenn er mit
der größten privatbank zusammen die die
menschen wirklich auf die straßen gehen
werden ich kann nichts sagen mehr sagen
ja immer so solange der deutsche
reagiert und sein fußball hat so ist er
lang ist sehr genügsam andere länder
wären schon längst da ich kann mir aber
gut vorstellen wenn ich bin ich mal
bezahlbar ist während fernsehen nicht
mehr funktioniert weil der strom uhr
santa ist und da man dann auch noch
friert und die eigenen kinder weinen
dann glaube ich schon dass das maß diese
rote linie diese rot grüne linie weit
überschritten ist und ich kann diese
bundesregierung sehen wir gerade noch
weit entfernt als wenn man sich zum
beispiel energiemonitor derzeit den kann
ich meinem verehrten schauen dann sieht
man schon sehr klar dass wir eigentlich
über diesen winter schon wahrscheinlich
gut kommen werden also dieses free
angebrannt ist ja noch nicht ja sagen
und ich denke auch zu welchem preis wie
sollen wir das bezahlen soll die kohle
her kommen wir können ja mal eins machen
vergessen war doch allemal wie haben
stolz er vergisst ja auch gerne einfach
mal die rechnung zu bezahlen vergisst
wäre doch allemal die rechnung zu
bezahlen hat wollen sie machen uns allen
den strom abdrehen und jetzt auch mal
andere kommen aus dessen glauben die
menschen können strom auch nicht mehr
bezahlen obwohl es wird auch
entlastungspaket gehen einhausen sollten
eigentlich den kompletten ja mal sagen
ich sehe ihn nicht den absoluten umsturz
aller straßen
ok ich glaube bloß dass die menschen die
es wirklich am nötigsten brauchen dabei
am wenigsten bekommen und dänischen
haben eine gasanlage und dann wollen wir
doch mal klar endlich feststellen er
eine gas umlagert von vom
wirtschaftsminister der für wirtschaft
zu ist da muss man doch klar sein wenn
wir ja schon gesagt dass er jetzt die
gasanlage verändern wird also super
sache das sagen doch mal für dass der
wirtschaftsminister das schon jetzt in
der lage ist zu erkennen dass da
vielleicht leute bescheißen wollen
haufen kohle haben und wir wie liebe
bürger und da zähle ich zu und viele von
ihnen ja hoch die sollen ja alles und
wir bürger ja ja ja eher oder andere
verdient ja du auch von uns bezahlt mit
meiner arbeit dazu wir sollen jetzt also
unternehmen die milliarden gewinne
gemacht haben über jahre hinweg wir
müssen sie jetzt über diese krise tragen
damit sie ihre gewinne nicht verlieren
aber wir sind nicht daran beteiligt
gewesen wenn sie gewinne machen ich sind
jetzt schon ein bisschen asozial und ein
bisschen vollkommen daneben ihr habt die
ganze zeit kohle geworden sind beteiligt
mit den steuern die unternehmen zahlen
wenn unternehmen viel verdienen geben
sie auch viel ab
die steuern aber sie über stephen e auch
oft gerne in andere dinge tochter
führung et cetera und katzi nennt auch
wieder geld ich würde vor allem gerne
mal eins wissen da steuern sind in
deutschland daher haben wir nicht mit
immer wieder wegkriegen manche sachen
schon aber wissen sie was mich ja vor
allem interessiert ich habe heute eine
eine schlagzeile gesehen wenn man doch
wenn man doch sanktionen schafft
sensation schafft dann sollten jedoch
eigentlich auch nutzen trafen und wenn
ich heute lese sehr das gastro
milliarden court gewinne macht dann
würde ich doch mal sagen irgendwann hat
mich so richtig funktioniert eine frage
hätte gegangen als jahre was ist das
eigentlich für das was wir kaufen wo
kommen wird wo kommt denn das her denn
vielleicht sind ja an so clever und
kaufen das gas da drehen es einmal ums
kicken andere catrin und kommt wieder
ins unser land zurück und einfach kommt
nur woanders her und wir zahlen kann
sich das gas was wir nicht haben wollten
so es wird blut diamanten aus afrika
kaufen aber kaufen sie woanders hier ich
will einfach nur mal wissen er habe
programm selbst da wurde nicht von der
regierung abgelehnt sondern durch nord
stream 1 wurde s gedrosselt das heißt
wir haben nicht gesagt wir wollen das
gas nicht mehr und darauf verzichtet
sondern das ist eine entscheidung aus
russland warum das gas gerade nicht mehr
rauskommt wie beziehen ist und das
wollen wir versuchen es absolut und tun
es auch aber wollen sie zu ihrer these
wir müssen noch zinsen kommen noch einen
ganz kurzen abschließenden appell zu
ihrem thema innenpolitik bänden ja ich
würde ganz einfach mal sagen liebe
politik vielleicht verletzter wand
blitzt die blase und geht man wirklich
zu den bürgern und als allererstes würde
ich mich für diese arroganz und ignoranz
und diese doppelmoral hier teilweise
jetzt die letzten monate verbracht hat
einfach mal entschuldigen und dann
einfach mal bürgernahe politik machen
und vor allen dingen wie wärs denn mal
wenn ihr anstatt euch in so einer krise
die diäten erhöht alle vielleicht mal
überlegen ob wir nicht mal ein bürger
vom aufmacht ich weiß ihr habt die
gesetze so geregelt dass man ist ja alle
nicht auf ihr geld verzichten könnt ihr
wart schon clever aber ihr könnt ja
eigentlich mal so ein teil ihres
gehaltes spenden in einem bürgerforum 25
prozent sind weiß man wird so zehn
prozent werden damit die bürger merken
dass wir auch daran beteiligt und nicht
wie eine frau stark zimmermann sagt wir
sollen opfer in tucson 7 ich wollte
einen streifen natürlich würden wir
wollen nicht dass sie im streit konnte
bot daher das möchten wir nicht
dementsprechend geben wir jetzt auch mal
weiter zu einem anderen sehr sehr
wichtigen thema und das geht um den
ehemaligen präsidenten gorbatschow und
ich würde gerne einmal eine rede
reinheim bevor wir über ihn reden 1999
die sehr bewegend ist
und wenn ich gefragt werde wer der
größte held der wiedervereinigung sei
bush kohl gorbatschow oder sonst jemand
dann sage ich in anerkennung unserer
gewissen verdienste
das deutsche volk und das russische volk
waren die mini med
sehr berührende worte von gorbatschow
und mobile hast ihn dir heute auch
mitgebracht als das thema des tages ja
zehn jahre war es damals hier dass die
mauer gefallen war besondere würdigung
vornehmlich gorbatschow vor dem
deutschen bundestag damals schon
reichstag in berlin
was mich aber viel mehr bewegt habe
vergisst dann als die nachricht kam
blickte auf twitter und da war das
einzige was kam dieser werbespot den
wiedersehen pizza hat also alles war
20.000 30.000 tweets gab es über pizza
hut und
michail gorbatschow das war nicht nur
ein gag sondern war auch eine politische
botschaft die zugleich tausendfachen mit
transportiert wurde dieser mann so hieß
es da hat nicht nur sein reich ruiniert
das erwähnt reicht sondern sich dann an
den westen verkauft inklusive diese
skizze an videos das war hat mich sehr
überrascht fand ich sehr ungerecht weil
es eine historische größe war und ist
die wir haben mit michael gorbatschow
und der wird in keiner weise den bereich
presse deutschland geleistet hat und für
die wellen denn ohne gorbatschow hätte
es nie diese öffnung gegeben in der
sowjetunion also perestroika es ist auch
kein glas ausgegeben ohne gorbatschow
hätte es wir haben es gesehen am rande
berlins mutige ansparen uhr gegeben als
spruch hier in berlin vor 35 jahren
mister gorbatschow open this gate und
es wäre nichts daraus gefolgt und ohne
gorbatschow hätte ich nehme an sicher in
der nacht vom neunten auf den zehnten
november
1989 irgendwann dann doch den
schießbefehl gegeben als nämlich
tausende von mutigen bürgern dann eine
indirekte aufforderung wahrgenommen
haben und daneben die grenzen gestürmt
haben ja und auch das muss man sagen
auch gorbatschow hatte seine dunklen
seiten es war nämlich kaum ein jahr da
war im amt da passierte tschernobyl ein
reaktor block explodierte die sowjets
haben damals alles unter den teppich
gekehrt die ukraine damals gehörte ja
noch zum sehr widrig und haben uns hier
im dunklen gelassen was die wahren
auswirkungen angeht 1000 von menschen
starben dort an diesen radioaktiven
verseuchungen auch dafür war
verantwortlich er hat aber daraus die
konsequenz gezogen und gesagt gelassen
hast ich gehe jetzt offen damit um
und viel wichtiger ist was er geschaffen
hat ohne gorbatschow und ohne seinen mut
ohne seinen willen hätte es keine
deutsche einheit gegeben und dafür
schulden wir ihm für immer
dankbar sein ja da gibt es nichts weiter
zu sagen es gibt natürlich jetzt noch zu
debattieren wie jetzt das begräbnis
aussehen wird von herr gorbatschow und
da ist jetzt natürlich die frage der cdu
chef friedrich merz hat er schon
gefordert dass alle staatschefs dahin
reisen werden ist es in der aktuellen
lage überhaupt möglich viversum
begräbnis vor dem ukraine krieg gewesen
wie wir das jetzt sein
naja das ist erstmal die frage des
ausrichters wenn man zu nehmen kann und
wenn es ein staatsbegräbnis wird dann
würde natürlich der russische staat und
diesem fall der russische präsident
darüber entscheidet das interessante ist
ja
in russland selbst nicht nur bei putin
war gorbatschow ja nicht unumstritten
ganz im gegenteil viele menschen werfen
ihm bis heute vor dass ihr das
sowjetreich zerstört hat durch seine art
und durch sein irgendwann da nicht
handeln das wird nicht von allen als
kämpfer für die demokratie wahrgenommen
sondern eben in russland auch von vielen
anders gesehen aber und gleichzeitig hat
er immer bis zuletzt für einen dialog
geworben mit russland auch unter putin
also obwohl putin und er sicherlich man
kann sagen verfeindet waren hat auch
gorbatschow bis zuletzt gesagt gebt das
reden miteinander nicht auf also die ur
idee der diplomatie die von hans
dietrich genscher gott hab ihn selig
immer so verkörpert wurde egal wie die
zeiten waren aber es und kalter krieg
war oder sonst also muss man sehen wie
die entscheidung wird sollte es ein
solches staatsbegräbnis geben dann geht
die einladung natürlich an das
staatsoberhaupt denke ich oder an den
regierungschef und dann muss man sich
darauf einlassen und natürlich wäre es
angemessen wenn deutschland der
hochrangigste repräsentiert wurde und
der bundespräsident und die
bundeskanzlerin fahren würden klar wie
hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
möglich sein wird das kann ich nicht
voraus in den russischen medien war der
tod von gorbatschow den russischen
medien wirklich nur 1 10 sekündige
ansage dass herr gorbatschow tod ist wer
hat keine doku keine lange rede würde
ich einfach nur dass er gestorben ist
dementsprechend ist wahrscheinlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit niedriger dass es
große staatsbegräbnis wird mit
staatschefs wie gesagt er war da kein
held dass das muss man einfach so sehen
auch in den meisten bei dem beim
großteil der bevölkerung nicht hier ist
ja auch uns natürlich ein begriff bei
jüngeren menschen noch nicht so wird
seiner rolle nicht gerecht und
vielleicht ist aber auch eine
gelegenheit zu sagen mir russischen
staates wir gucken mal wer kommt in
einer solchen phase dann erpresst auf
würde denn die fdp-spitze also würden
sie den vorschlag unterstützen von herr
merz dass sie hin reisen sollten ich
glaube man muss tatsächlich erst einmal
schauen ob das begräbnis von michael
gorbatschow für putin
ein solches ereignis überhaupt werden
würde ich glaube nicht dass es zu seiner
agenda passt
gorbatschow steht für werte wie putin
nicht teilt für ein offenes russland für
ein russland der öffnung auch so zum
westen hin dass er genau wie gegen
überlegungen die putin jetzt macht und
warum sollte in dieser situation der
sich jetzt gerade befindet in einem
krieg der nicht läuft er wo er in einem
sehr vagen situation sich befindet warum
sollte er da jemanden groß ehren der
genau für die entgegensetzen werte steht
jetzt würden damit würde sie sicherlich
eine flanke auf machen und ich glaube
dass wir hier auch grundsätzlich gucken
müssen wenn sie eine einladung kommt wie
wir das auch im europäischen kontext
handhaben wie wir das mit unseren
partnern zusammen machen ich glaube das
ist keine zeit für alleingänge ist sie
muss man sich gemeinsam auch im
europäischen rahmen abstimmen wünscht
man sich nicht manchmal als bürger auch
politiker die auch mal nach dem herzen
entscheiden also wenn ich jetzt an einen
herrn genscher beispielsweise denke muss
man nicht mal überlegen ob man es dann
machen sollte ohne vielleicht alle
europäischen partner erst mal zu fragen
der politik ist ja doch immer ein
bisschen mehr als nur das herz es ist
halt auch verstand und das ist dann auch
viele zusammenhänge die ich beachten
müssen wir finden uns gerade einer
großen krise und wir haben auch mit
russland gemeinsam eine große krise und
da kann man nicht business as usual
machen ich glaube wäre das vor zwei
jahren passiert ist ein staatsbegräbnis
gegeben hätte sich gar keiner gefragt ob
man dahin fährt dabei selbstverständlich
verständlich gewesen wir können den tod
auch nicht nur aus dem kontext reisen
und auch eine solche veranstaltung nicht
und ich finds natürlich märz auch nicht
angebracht ehrlich gesagt dieses thema
zu nutzen um politische spielchen zu
treiben denn das ist gefährlich das
macht keinen sinn wo ist der politische
spielchen werden die sache bis zum
beispiel von béla anda gehört steht ja
noch gar nicht fest in welchem rahmen
auf dem staatsbegräbnis stattfinden wird
also wenn friedrich merz gesagt sie
sollten hinreisen ist ja kein
politisches spiel ist ja noch niemand
abgesagt ja es ist schon natürlich ein
aufbruch von der druck kulisse ja das
ist erwartungen zu äußern natürlich
erwarte ich dass die bundesregierung
dorthin reist damit baue ich ja schon
etwas auf und nun probiere eine
erzählung auch aufzubauen vielleicht die
die in diesem fall aus meiner sicht
nicht angemessen ist ich finde das ist
eine form des respekts unser land ist
ein einheit das verdanken wir vor allem
in diesen mann dieser mann den
schießbefehl gegeben hat denn viele
menschen gestorben das wäre nie dazu
gekommen all das was wir heute sind
eine nation ein land verdanken wir
diesen mann und es ist eine form des
respekts klar wenn putin dass dort nicht
machen sollte vielleicht überrascht er
uns aber macht sowas dann sollte unser
politische spitze und besonders stolz
der gerade in so einer krise ist als
wahrscheinlich schon wieder vergessen
hat sollte sich vielleicht überlegen das
vielleicht zu nutze und wenn er das
nicht macht dann sollte er sich fort
kanzler anstellen und vielleicht die
fahne hissen oder zumindest denken dass
man diesen mandant öffentlich dank für
das was er gemacht hat denn nochmal wir
alle da waren wir noch klären wäre
wander noch klinisch suchen ja da da
sollten wir dankbar sein dass wir heute
drin sind übrigens man nur davon
abgesehen mainz nebenbei meine kinder
sind zur hälfte polnisch ich hätte diese
kinder gar nicht wenn dieser mann
gewesen wäre und deshalb nicht dass
dieser respekt ihm gegenüber sehr sehr
wichtig ist ich weiß politische
spielchen sind ja normal es geht ja
immer nur um politik aber menschlichkeit
ist denn du wirst du denn ich will euch
dort nur noch mal in erinnerung rufen
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
ja aber aber soll man in einer situation
in der russische truppen
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine beginnt
ein staatsbegräbnis beiwohnen wo ich
neben russischen soldaten deutsche
regierungsmitglieder stehen da ja
ein g20 gipfel haben in wenigen wochen
tunesien da kommen die 20
wirtschaftsstärksten nationen dieser
welt und der russische präsident hat
angekündigt ich fahr dahin ja ja ist ja
kein es ist kein russisches
staatsbegräbnis
zu verdanken hat eine breite schulter
oder sagen da müssen wir uns erstmal im
europäischen allein vor ihm eine pizza
hut was das so stehen zu lassen finde
ich meinen sohn heute frage was er nicht
mehr ist zeigt mir schon wieder wie die
geschichte auch in den schulen teilweise
vermittelt wird fehlt ja aber sie kann
ihren sohn beibringen was hab ich aber
sicher nachweisen
er weiß warum wir heute warum wir heute
diese freiheit hat die andere in dem
land mit anderen ländern nicht mehr
hatte die verdankt das sehr sortieren
bürger dass die wiedervereinigung in
deutschland erlebt und auch herr
gorbatschow die rolle selbst ja ich
meine noch zu wissen dass wir damals zu
der zeit sogar in berlin waren mit der
mannschaft und wir dann selber noch eine
mauer waren und steine heraus geschlagen
haben das weiß ich noch habe ich jetzt
noch im gedächtnis und wenn das nicht
passiert wäre dann hätte ich meine frau
nicht kennengelernt und sie ist aus
ostberlin und wir sind verheiratet wir
haben eine tochter und ich kann nur mein
hut davor ziehen was die damaligen herrn
herbert schaffen herr kohl gemacht haben
und das finde ich einfach klasse und bin
froh dass das damals absolut passiert
ist also müssen sich also dem appell
anfang der andere ja ich habe da immer
probleme mit es wird immer alles tot
geredet es wird immer alles kaputt
geredet man kann doch einfach mal das
herz entscheiden lassen und die gefühle
entscheiden lassen da ist natürlich
schwer für viele die politik treiben ja
die auch aus meiner sicht mit denen ich
zu tun habe realitätsfremd entfernen
sind das beschäftigt mich seit vielen
jahren
einsatz vorhin noch meine mutter hat
mich vor zwei wochen angerufen und sagte
weißt du ich hab das mal durchgerechnet
ich habe jetzt schon 100 euro weniger im
monat da kriege ich denn da laufen wir
die tränen sind zu hause die tränen
gelaufen diese menschen werden vergessen
unsere kinder werden vergessen und wir
haben nur immer irgendwelche ideen
fahren wir dahin haben wir das haben wir
dass die probleme haben wir hier hier
haben wir die probleme und das ist für
mich etwas wo ich wirklich ein riesiges
problem mit ja heute noch ein anderes
thema mitgebracht was sie sehr bewegt
und
ja ich bin ja seite jetzt über 22 jahren
trocken trockener alkoholiker ich war 16
jahre profi 16 jahre 14 jahre
medikamenten wenn ich vier jahre
spielsüchtig habe mich dann daraus
geholt und bin jetzt unterwegs in ganz
deutschland suchtprävention seit zehn
jahren ich bin auf der straße ich habe
sogar im experiment teilgenommen und war
in frankfurt am main wo hab da bei minus
16 grad zweieinhalb tage nächte
verbracht und habe mir das ganze
angeschaut es war absoluter wahnsinn
weil ich selbst weiß was auf der straße
passiert wir sind für suchtprävention
unterwegs ich verbiete nicht ich komme
nicht er und seine familie jetzt den
euro wirklich die frau ich habe die
probleme damit gab ich konnte das nicht
kontrollieren und bin deswegen haben
alles verloren alles was ich mir
aufgebaut habe verloren bin aber wieder
aufgestanden und heute kümmern wir uns
um menschen um kinder und ich gehe nicht
hin und sagen wir müssen alles verbieten
einig mit 60 jahren erreiche die kinder
in der schule mit 14 15 jährigen gehören
wir zu soll das sind die themen die sie
wissen wollen heute alkohol drogen
medikamente
internet-handy spielsucht amphetamine
unser lacht unser land wir leben in
einem suchtkranken land und das ist das
was ich sehr weil ich jeden tag auf der
straße bin vor zehn jahren bin ich
ausgelacht worden weil ich gesagt habe
wir müssen prävention wir müssen in
schulen wir müssen mit den kindern reden
wir müssen mit den erwachsenen reden wie
erwachsene sind die vorbilder für unsere
kinder und wenn sie das sehen was da
draußen abgeht das hat nicht mehr viel
mit vorbild zu tun morgens um zehn wenn
die kinder fußball spielen stehen zehn
eltern damit der pole das kann nicht
sein und ich sage wir brauchen einen
verantwortungsvollen umgang wir müssen
die vorbilder sein weil wir schaden
unserer gesundheit das soziale leben
geht kaputt die finanzielle krise kommt
noch obendrauf und eins ist ja auch klar
menschen die mehr belastet sind die
jeden tag druck hektik und stress
driften ab in die sucht und da setzen
wir uns für ein packen ihr buch gelesen
haben sie ja ich habe heute
durchgelesen und angeschaut und da fand
ich ganz spannend wie sie beschrieben
werden auch als fußballer auch in dem
vorwort dass sie eigentlich fehlendes
talent was andere wahl mehr hatten durch
fleiß und disziplin weg gemacht haben
eigentlich ja was was vier
bewundernswerter ist als wenn man vom
talent geküsst haben sie denn schon
während ihrer profikarriere auch
getrunken und er waren sie da noch
komplett ontrack nein ich war 16 jahre
parallel alkoholiker die
alkoholkrankheit ist ja eine
schleichende krankheit der körper
brauche über alle jahre mehr ich sage
ihnen jetzt mal in den letzten jahren in
bremen habe ich einen tageskonsum gehabt
dadurch getrunkene kiste bier eine
flasche wodka flasche ist wie haben sie
das geschafft wenn dann sie gelobt
werden in dem vorwort dafür dass sie
diese disziplin und diesen willen hat
iris wie gut werden so der lang gewesen
wenn sie nicht gesoffen tel nicht viel
besser es nicht viel besser nein das
haben wir alles nachgeschaut ich hätte
vielleicht vom alter her vielleicht ein
jahren noch länger in der bundesliga
spielen können oder im ausland ich habe
wahnsinnig viel glück gehabt das haben
wir jahre später festgestellt
der stoffwechsel eines menschen ist
immer anders und ich habe teilweise bis
drei uhr morgens gesoffen und warum 9
uhr der erste um trainings blatt ich
habe keinen dicken kopf gehabt mir war
nicht schlecht und ich bin vorweg
marschiert wie das alles funktioniert
hat hat mit dem körper zu tun mit dem
stoffwechsel der eine oder andere trinkt
am freitag mal ein glas wein oder zwei
und hat sonntags immer noch
kopfschmerzen bei mir war das nicht so
und so bin ich heute auch durch ville
durch ehrgeiz durch fleiß habe ich mir
das alles erarbeitet er und heute sage
ich ihnen auch das habe ich vor zwei
jahren noch nicht gemacht erst nachdem
mich da zwei tage und zwei nächte bei 16
grad minus heute bin ich stolz auf die
22 einhalb jahre ja weil das ist ein
viel größerer schritt ich habe einige
titel gewonnen ich habe dreimal gegen
maradona gespielt aber wissen sie jeden
tag den ich trocken bin der ist für mich
wichtiger wie jeden titel den ich mal
gewonnen habe und so gehe ich in die
schulen so bin ich unterwegs so versuche
ich durch corona wahrgenommen dass das
zunimmt das trinken der gesellschaft die
psychologische probleme durch die krone
haslam müssen die korona hat einen
flächenbrand ausgelöst wir werden so
viele suchtkranke menschen bekommen und
psychisch belastete menschen und die
psyche und die sucht die geht so
ineinander über menschen die psychisch
belastet sind die existenzängste haben
die nicht mehr wissen wie sie die kinder
ob sie dennoch schon kaufen können oder
nicht die rutschen ab in die sucht
vielleicht auch erst wenn die
medikamente oder wie auch immer oder sie
bringen sich und bringt sich um viel
mehr kinder die auch eben mit dem sport
aufgehört haben ich habe jetzt ein
neuesten studie über zwei millionen
kinder gehen nicht mehr tagtäglich zum
sport hier sind überwiegt übergewichtig
ja wir haben 13 13 millionen menschen
gerne armutsgrenze leben im land bremen
prozent kindes armut aber in bremen
streiten sich die politiker wer oder
unter oder über der brücke darf seit
zwei jahren der fahrradfahrer fahren
dahinter wird mir anders das sind das
sind doch keine probleme das sind
probleme wenn die kinderarmut da ist
wenn die kinder abrutschen und ich sehe
es ich sehe es tagtäglich und dann
kommen noch politiker her und sagen man
soll cannabis legalisieren
das sind die sachen er irgendein
politiker darüber geben cannabis
legalisieren ist ja auch in ihrer partei
um beispielsweise aber vor allem wenn
sie jetzt hören was die korona maßnahmen
ausgelöst haben es ist denn dann richtig
dass eigentlich ja die ampel den weg
bereitet hat das massen fliegt
beispielsweise in schulen wieder ab
herbst umsetzbar ist also man kann ich
sagen ich bin sehr froh dass wir jetzt
in der regierung sind und das ist halt
nicht zu locker uns kommen wird und zu
keinen schulen schließen
ich denke ich denke dass ich denke dass
ein ganz großer unterschied zu dem
vorgänger regierung dass wir gesagt hat
es gibt keine lockt es gibt keine
schulung ist was ja in china übrigen
auch frühestens ab der fünften klasse
und auch nur wenn es eine ernsthafte
gefährdung des des präsenzunterricht es
gibt weil wir schulschließung da müssen
sehr gemeinden ausgerufen naja das ist
gar nicht so einfach dieses
tatbestandsmerkmal zu erfüllen da muss
man schon einiges schaffen und ich denke
dass das ein deutlicher unterschied ist
zudem und die probleme die entstanden
sind und da der beruf für vollkommen
recht ist dass wir zwar sport treiben an
frischer luft ja unter freiem himmel
untersagt haben für kinder das war eine
große katastrophe kinder brauchen kinder
um zu wachsen ja um brauchen soziale
interaktion
großen respekt vor uli borowka also dass
ich meine wir kennen so ein bisschen die
geschichte aber das noch mal so zu hören
und und und und so dabei zu sein und zu
sehen was sie da geleistet haben das ist
unglaublich und wirklich super respekt
wer was sie sagen mit den kindern ja ich
mein jüngster sohn musste der konnten
auch sport machen durfte dann mit maske
bei 30 grad herum rennen draußen war es
noch schule war
aber was ich heute gelesen hat es gab
hier so ein programm um die schulen
auszustatten mit lüftern also
energie nein noch schlimmer 200
millionen euro bahn bereit 22 prozent
abgerufen also 444 46 millionen euro der
lässt nicht gebracht hat kein mensch
sich gut weil zu komplizieren zur auf
wen genau das ist das genehmigung und
gegen herne hin und her das programm ist
mittlerweile ausgelaufen
160 millionen liegen da viele viele
schulen haben diese länder nicht und
warten nur darauf dass der herbst
beginnt bis dann wohlmöglich wieder dann
die maßnahmen kommen die sie beschrieben
haben und ob das nun ab sechster klar
sehen oder siebter ist mir wirklich
völlig egal das ist jede klasse die da
rein kommt weil diese lüfter nicht da
sind nicht abgerufen werden ist eine zu
viel die anfrage der trevo dass das
gefährlich wir haben sehr früh das
einführen von diesen luftfilter systemen
schulen gefordert wir haben uns in
berlin sehr stark für gemacht dass das
passiert berlin hat auch ein eigenes
landesprogramm aufgesetzt auch wenn du
dich nicht regieren muss man sagen da
wurde einiges geschafft aber ich muss
ich widersprechen man ja aber ich muss
ich widersprechen wenn sagen das ist
egal auf welcher klar sind das ist
nämlich nicht in den ersten vier klassen
habe ich die schule eingangsphase damit
ist noch sehr viel lesen schreiben
rechnen die grundlagen
brauch ich ja das ist vollkommen ich
aber ich brauche gerade in diesen
klassen den kontakt zum lehrer den
augenkontakt ich muss sehen wie werden
laute gebildet das dass wir das auf
jeden fall schon mal gestoppt haben die
kindliche bildung
das ist wieder gelten kann ist eine
möglichkeit die unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen
stehe dann hinter dem war es damit wenn
die schulschließung vermieden werden
kann dadurch ja weil schulschließungen
eine große katastrophe sind ich kann nur
eins sagen jetzt will ich bin kein
kinderschutz ist mein thema mein thema
seit neun jahren mache ich kennen uns
schon eine weile wir machen beide
prävention ich gewaltprävention und ich
kämpfe gegen missbrauch und gegen gewalt
und gegen das man kinder quert der fall
jetzt in europa zum beispiel eine
katastrophenfall und viele viele andere
bei ihr den kindern angetan habt ihr die
politik auf dem rücken der kinder wir
haben euch davor gewarnt dass der
missbrauch steigen wird dass die gewalt
steigen wir haben eine 4 100 prozentige
zunahme von suiziden und ihr fangt mit
dem schwachsinn schon wieder an ihr habt
nichts evaluiert ihr habt diese
maßnahmen nicht evaluiert die männer
waren wurden immer zu haben aber das
heißt nicht dass masken in der schule zu
missbrauch führen ist ein blödsinn
schulschließung und die fehlende soziale
kontrolle waren das problem warum wir
mehr misshandlungen zu hause jetzt
fangen wir wieder an
schließungen verhindern darum müssen wir
ja kindern die möglichkeit geben aus
ihrem zuhause alle anderen länder
drumherum an der anderen momentan alles
runter und behandelte ganz anders wir
machen immer weiter an keine gehören wie
genau darum geht es noch eine ganz kurze
unterbrechung dies eigentlich die
anderen länder machen ob man sich ja
eigentlich dafür feiern sollte dass
schulschließungen jetzt erstmal nicht
mehr kommen bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich einen lauterbach und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen sind meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht privat jet ski erlitten das
auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur derart zu überlassen lasst den
leuten soll man den spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten deren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig durch
vielleicht einmal kurz an
doch das ist übliche andrack träger
ausdrücken ich hatte meinen beifall um
eine sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand dass israel den anderen
ist er ganz klein auch darüber sprechen
das ist einfach nicht fair mich richtig
wohl ist die aufgabe von journalismus
einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
mein thema heute abend frankreichs
präsident marco hat die pandemie für
beendet erklärt vive la france in
frankreich gilt kaum noch eine krone
regel mit dem virus leben das ist die
maxime dort vor ort wer in diesen tagen
also von deutschland nach frankreich dem
zug fährt der wird ein denkwürdiges
spiel erleben denn bis zur grenze maske
auf in frankreich das geweckt man fragt
sich schon ob es sind frankreich einen
anderen corona virus gibt als in
deutschland
dabei eigentlich der fall die franzosen
haben sich nur einfach dazu entschieden
mit ihm zu nehmen es gibt noch die
empfehlung das sind groß und
schulgebäuden belüftet wird aber
ansonsten lebt es sich in frankreich im
vorjahr pandemie und was besonders schön
ist was mich besonders freut die
experten zeigen anders erzählt zu lande
wo wir panik lauter bereits
gesundheitsminister haben einsicht als
expertenrat aufgelöst wurde fand sein
langjähriger vorsitzender der immer nur
monologe der fresse kritische worte über
die politik zitat natürlich bedauere ich
vieles sagte er in einem radiointerview
wir haben manchmal die gesundheit über
die menschlichkeit gestellt einige
bewohner von altenheimen in lebenswillen
verloren und nur noch auf den tod
gewartet weil sie angehören nicht mehr
sehen durften das hatten wir auch hier
in diesem land in deutschland aber von
dieser einsicht kann man hierzulande nur
träumen
was mich brennend interessieren würde
ist jetzt natürlich die frage ein herz
kreislauf waren es keine ko- herr
maßnahmen ergeben wird
ja das sollte ist ja politik geben die
daten nennen und
nach seiner eingefangen werden damit ich
denke wir werden sehen wie sich der
winter und herbst entwickelt und ob die
maßnahmen die jetzt im
infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt wurden
überhaupt anwendung finden werden denn
es ist ja einfach nur das eine fürsorge
oder vorsorge getroffen wurde mit diesem
gesetz und keine anwendung geschlossen
das heißt die länder haben die
möglichkeit diese regeln anzuwenden
sollten kritische situation entstehen
warum machen wir das so früh weil wir
ein anderes system haben als frankreich
zum beispiel jede grundrechts
einschränkungen mussten der
bundesrepublik deutschland durch das
parlament gehen was auch wichtig ist und
was auch gut so ist eine lehre aus
unserer geschichte dass wir dies auch so
tun in anderen ländern kann das mit dem
präsidialerlass sofort gemacht werden
wir haben
wir haben immer einen vorlauf bei
solchen sachen das heißt ich muss eine
vorsorge teil bin ich einfach nicht
verantwortungsvoll meine rolle als
politiker so und diesem baukasten haben
wir gepackt ich denke er ist nicht
übervoll sondern eher so dass maßnahmen
drin sind die zu einer eindämmung
geeignet sein können aber ich muss erst
einmal schauen unter welchen
voraussetzungen werden diese von den
ländern aufgerufen und da werden wir
ganz genau hingucken denn grundrechts
einschränkung ist immer die ultima ratio
in einer demokratie und da werden auch
wir als freie demokraten ganz genau
schauen wie es in welchem land wir
sehen das ganze dilemma der ampel
regierung die muss eine
freiheitsliebende partei und ich denke
mal fest steht genauso für diese
richtung auch obwohl hier ein bisschen
was anderes verkündet mit einer staats
dirigistischen und einer staatsgläubigen
partei zusammenarbeiten um irgendwie die
menschen zu
mitzuteilen dass das was sie tun richtig
ist ist es aber nicht denn wir sehen es
in vielen anderen ländern auch dass die
möglichkeiten zurück gegeben werden an
die bürger eigentlich einen bürgerinnen
und bürger eigentlich eine uhr forderung
der fdp warum kann man den menschen
nicht sagen leute ihr seid alt genug
mittlerweile auch kenntnisreich genug
euch zu schützen wer maske tragen will
soll sie tragen in der bahn und im
flieger so wie das in frankreich der
fall ist wer nicht wird auch nicht
diskriminiert sondern er soll sich
ebenso dar einsetzen mittlerweile sind
wir doch so weit dass wir eben
entsprechend auch handeln und agieren
können und dieses dieses dieses zu
vertrauen kann ich doch mittlerweile im
dritten jahr von gruner den menschen ab
verlangen und auch gewähren anstatt sie
weiter zu dirigieren und die
verantwortlichkeiten zu verschieben in
die länder wo es natürlich unterschiede
gibt da gibt es den einen der sagt ja
mach ich doch ein bisschen stärker
staatsdirigismus der andere sagt naja
schauen wir erstmal was passiert so wird
es doch kommen der leidtragende werden
die bürgerinnen und bürger sein und
nicht die politiker die sich dann wir
haben es gesehen irgendwo nach kanada 12
stunden dann mit maske fliegen lassen
und eben nicht die maske trägt ja aber
sie werden kann locker uns mehr haben es
wird keine maut geben die gibt es in
diesen instrumenten
keine lockt bei uns mehr es geht nicht
um dankbar es geht darum dass man
überlegt hat welche maßnahmen können
hilfreich sein
erste mission erklärt johanna stadler
weg der gegengerade von frankreich
erzählt ich kann auch andere länder an
der weilheimer krone mich so machen kann
und mit einer präsidialen verordnung das
ganze thema einfach regelt in
deutschland haben wir den deutschen
bundestag ein gesetz das muss ein gesetz
ändern muss mit dem gesetz
werde man sicher noch tragen muss jetzt
nicht so als wäre man in frankreich sagt
lenka lauterbach das ist doch das
entscheidende frage hat kein panik
minister comedian und was auch noch so
alles ist das war nur ein auge trends
nicht die renten sollten weiter machen
das ist ein etwas jungen dem auftritt
einer version anwendungen her es ist
halt einfach so wenn ich mir das
angehört das immer an ist ich bin ganz
nah an den bürgern besonders an den
kindern und die kriege dieses land seit
jahren immer wieder fragt man mich
kommst du mit auf demos kannst du den
tätern machen ich weiß ja wie die presse
immer macht es doch so eine demo und
schon bist du wieder ein junge sie haben
es ja vorhin gesagt oder du hast gesagt
wenn die kinder endlich der masken
machen da geht es erst mal auf der
straße ist mal wieder aufpassen wenn ich
danach mache das auch wieder nicht
irgendwelche schmuggler irgendwie
komisch aber jetzt ist das wort der
moment ein bisschen weg dann vielleicht
die merkt das gar nicht so viele dinge
wir sind dann aber für mich ist ganz
klar ja einmal lügt dem glaubt man nicht
und ich habe noch nie so viele
widersprüche ungehalten und auch lügen
gehört wie von lauterbach einer
bockwurst eine bockwurst hat mehr
glaubwürdigkeit als dieser minister
haben wir machen immer weiter und wir
dass ihnen weiter gewähren er möchte in
mittel bockwurst ist jetzt etwas
überspitzt immer meine hobbys stelle
natürlich der box eine menge schaden an
entscheidend ist für mich es geht um die
bürger und diese freiheitseinschränkung
dir passieren auf den rücken vor allen
dingen der menschen gesehen die haben
gelernt damit zu leben ich muss mal
gucken ob ich vielleicht französisch
lernen muss und meinen pass abbiegen da
sollten wir darüber gehen weil es geht
ja immer weiter und hat einzige was die
beiden lauter waren unter den immer
wieder höre ist
impfen sind der 98 wir haben jetzt
bessere die alten socken gar nicht mehr
mit das ist es vielleicht sollte dann
doch gleich in die pharma lobby gehen
vielleicht will er dann seinen posten
wie man ihn vielleicht vielleicht
erkennt ja immer so ein ding wenn ich
antrete ich weiß es nicht aber wie lange
die freiheitsliebende politik partei
macht ihr denn eigentlich noch mit bevor
ihr endlich mal sagt es reicht
zumindest für diese politik einfach
aufgaben sie die gleiche temperatur oder
gehen das sind ganz klein wenig ruhiger
weil ich ein bisschen älter bin aber
runde im grunde sehen wir kämpfen wir
beide ja in der gleichen richtung weit
und wenn ich das so sehe ich meine
hälfte beider lager war nah nein wir
setzen uns weiter für die sachen ein und
alles und ich muss meinen satz dazu
sagen wo sie alles beschlossen haben
alle parteien da ging es relativ schnell
mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz und
ruckzuck war das ding erledigt aber
jetzt zurück wo man was gemeint da geht
wieder nix da schiebt einer dem anderen
die verantwortung zu ja und das ist
einfach nicht in ordnung alles geht
alles funktioniert wenn sie in eine
richtung geht aber zurück drehen ich
habe damit nichts zu tun ich will damit
nichts zu tun haben und da muss ich
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen das hat nichts
mehr mit der realität zu tun was auf der
straße passiert was mit den menschen
passiert was mit den kindern passiert
was mit den bürgern passiert und sie
machen sich gedanken tagein tagaus das
geht immer drei vier monate fünf monate
sechs monate und nichts passiert und das
ist das dilemma was wir in deutschland
haben und das stimmt nicht mehr wie
traurig ich muss sagen ich habe sie
haben uns ein bisschen angesprochen hat
mittlerweile hohen respekt ich war am
anfang ja auch ich war für die
impfpflicht und sowas das habe ich dann
alles nicht alles aber ich hab es dann
revidiert dann auch und läutet er war am
anfang mehr dafür und so stimmt der
beine
stellen wie geht aber ich habe hohen
respekt vor den menschen die wirklich
demonstrieren ich war letztens in
münchen sagt mal tatsächlich im café und
auf einmal war ich wusste nicht haben
also ein demonstrationszug dann und es
waren viele viele menschen und das waren
ganz eine frau kam zu mir sagt ich bin
heute hier zum ersten mal in meiner
mitte war 53 jahre alt sagt ich bin 53
ich bin zum ersten mal bei einer demo
dabei ich arbeite im medizinischen
bereich das ist mir wichtig und hat es
mir erklärt was und so ist das und viele
viele menschen sind da obwohl sie
stigmatisiert werden sie wurden im
letzten winter von der polizei zum teil
davon abgehalten zu demonstrieren als
eben unter corona schutzmaßnahmen solche
demos und ansammlungen verboten wurden
sie werden jetzt stigmatisiert wie jeder
das möglicherweise gegen gegen die
steigenden öl- gas- und ölpreise wenden
wird als rechte bande wurde die stigma
sieht als querdenker und gehen trotzdem
demonstrieren und er sind halt zum
großen großen teil wirklich besorgte
menschen besorgt darüber wie experte mal
sagen was eigentlich hinter stehen
morgen ist ein problem der gesellschaft
nicht der schulen und was da passiert
diese vorangetriebene spaltung das ist
gezielt das ist auch im mittel in der
politischen seite gewesen in dem moment
es ist immer eine gruppendynamik dem
gruppenzwang wenn man anfängt leute und
deutschland sind sehr gefährlich hat die
missstände anspricht als der die
missstände macht und zu verantworten hat
in dem moment mit dem finger auf andere
zeigt und sie in eine bestimmte ecke
drückte dafür etwas schuldig spricht
dann machen einige mit manche sind davon
überzeugt manche auch wir müssen aber ob
ich mitmachen und dann ist es eine form
des mobbings mobbing bedeutet übrigens
ausgrenzen andere ausschließen und
spalten und das war ein willkommenes
mittel dieser politik diesen menschen zu
machen und besonders wenn prominente dem
mund aufgemacht hat hat man gleich drauf
gehauen hat es bei chemisch gesehen ist
das ein recht über seinen körper zu
bestimmen nein denn wurde ein exempel
statuiert dass alle anderen promis sein
mund halten bei mir war's so ich hab mal
gesagt ich hatte eine sendung bei einem
sender ja dann hat man mich angerufen
sagt gassen wo wir strahlen kann seine
sendung aus könntest du ja extra ubisoft
ich werde jetzt gar nichts sagen die
drei wochen wo die sendung läuft nee wir
wollten eigentlich das tuten statement
gibt dass du dich davon distanziert habe
ich gesagt bitte wenn er war das denn
herrscht also rtl 2 mit meiner sendung
war er dann auf einmal weg und hat
gesagt habe ich ein scheißdreck tun ich
sage ja nicht meine eigenen werte
verraten dann stampft die sendung eines
mir bist mir vorkommt worauf sein haben
sie dieses jahr noch nicht weg gewesen
dann ist halt so scheiß auf rtl2 aber
scheiß nicht auf unsere kinder unsere
bürger ihm habe ich doch nicht zum
verräter für meine eigenen für meine
eigenen werte nur finden so beschissen
sender oder wegen so einer sendung und
ist der unterschied weil der charakter
zeigt sich und viele promis schweigen
weil sie gesehen haben bei anderen waren
viele kinder mit vielen kannst du hast
vollkommen recht wird sie öffentlich
sagen weil man genau weil man angst hat
geschätzt zu werden weil man angst
gehabt ausgegrenzt zu werden das wundert
wenn die scheiße wieder von vorne
anfängt ja dann werdet ihr diesmal
merken das wird nicht so läuft er großen
respekt dass sie auf ihre sendung
verzichte scheiß drauf geht um kinder
gut aber trotzdem werden wir jetzt auch
den respekt herr fresdorf
entgegenbringen den erben 2 doch seitdem
war vorstellen dürfen ja und das geht
nicht um nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als um das aufstiegsversprechen in
unserer gesellschaft zu erneuern das
große problem das wir haben ist dass wir
eine große abhängigkeit haben zwischen
bildungserfolg und herkunft der kinder
und das müssen wir durchbrechen wenn wir
wollen das hat hier nicht verabredet
dass wir keine generationen von
hartz-iv-familien erzeugen da müssen wir
schauen dass nicht der goldenen löffel
im mund entscheidend ist sondern die
schätze im kopf für das was ein mensch
erreichen kann um seines glückes schmied
zu sein und das ist das große problem
was wir haben und wenn ich mir meine
heimatstadt berlin anschaue da ist die
abhängigkeit von der herkunft und
bildungserfolg extrem maßgebend und das
müssen wir durchbrechen und zwar sehr
schnell wenn wir nicht große teile der
bevölkerung für immer in eine bestimmte
richtung schieben wollen und der
bildungsarmut ist auch ein großes
problem was wir haben und das müssen wir
durchbrechen da geht es um frühkindliche
bildung die wir deutlich verstärken
müssen wir müssen die kinder früh dahin
bringen dass sie wenn sie in die schule
kommen auch der schule folgen können wir
haben viele viele kinder die in die
schule kommen und das sind nicht in der
lage sind dem unterricht zu folgen das
muss man sich einmal vorstellen werden
bildungsverlierer produziert von einem
system und wir schaffen es nicht sich
aufzufangen und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass wir bildung als
aufstiegs chance brauchen wir wissen
alle wir haben einen fachkräftemangel in
deutschland die köpfe unserer menschen
sind unsere ressourcen in diesem land
die wand ist echt brechen durch durch
eine bessere bildung wir müssen
tatsächlich viel früher anfangen mit
bildung und wir haben die idee
entwickelt in berlin zu sagen wir hätten
gerne wieder stärkere vorschulische
arbeit in den kindertagesstätten und
zwar mit einer pflicht des besuchs im
letzten kita-jahr das tatsächlich jedes
kind einmal in der kita war
und dann auch dort auf die schule
vorbereitet wird und wenn nicht dann
noch nicht so weit bin dass sich der
schule noch nicht folgen kann ja weil
die sprachliche defizit habe vielleicht
auch
noch nicht so weit bin als individuum
das haben wir immer wieder dass kinder
auch jetzt schon zurück gestellt wenn in
den kindertagesstätten soll ich dann
auch dieses jahr noch mal wiederholen
damit kinder sobald sie die schule
erreichen in der lage sein ansatz zu
probieren den eltern schon direkt zu
helfen als wir haben zb 500.000 freie
jobs fast in diesem land das man
vielleicht probiert mehr menschen aus
hartz 4 in die jobs zu kriegen dass sie
selber versorgen können für eine bessere
absolut aber hier geht es
tatsächlich gar nicht um das ökonomische
problem der eltern unbedingt sondern es
geht darum den bildungserfolg der kinder
davon abzukoppeln ja also natürlich
müssen wir gucken dass so viele menschen
wie möglich in arbeit kommen aber für
mich ist wichtig dass diese kinder alle
chancen haben den offen stehen und dass
sie nach ihrem leistungsvermögen den
besten abschluss hinbekommen ja das muss
nicht immer das aber immer nur sagen nur
weil im großen respekt der fresdorf und
ich würde das gar nicht ich will dass er
sei zwei mal respekt ich meins aber
wirklich weiß ein total wichtiges thema
ist aber wir diskutieren darüber seit 30
jahren seit seit ich meine willy brandt
der hat das gemacht rot grün hat damals
ganztagsschulen programm aufgesetzt 16
jahre lang ist nichts passiert unter der
großen koalition leider auch nicht nur
dass schwarz gelb in dieser richtung das
thema kauen wir sie können aber
wahrscheinlich
sagen einsatz funktionieren sie ihre
partei stellt doch die
bildungsministerin die den namen kennt
kein mensch ich habe von der auch nichts
gelesen nichts gehört an initiativen
und ich denke schon sie haben da einiges
schon gelesen haben dass da das da was
passiert ich weiß das ist ländersache
aber es gab mal eine zeit da gab es
impulse verrückt wir werden jetzt heute
einfach mit dem appell schließen schade
da haben sie jetzt mal ein thema wo sie
mich auf meiner seite halten ja
[Musik]